this giant box that you see right here
in front of me arrived today down in our
mail room for our apartment complex and
i've been expecting this for a while a
buddy of mine a friend former client now
now a good friend who
reads a lot of books and sometimes will
buy books and then
you know be done with them send them to
me or he'll get books on kindle that
he's got in his library and then he'll
he'll ship them off to other people he
wrote me and said i've got a whole bunch
of books on stoicism that i've got
kindle editions for and i'm wondering if
you know anybody who can give them a
good home and i said well i'll take them
and if i've got duplicates of these i'll
send them on to other people as well i
can find some good places for these so
this came and this is a monster box this
is the biggest shipment of books i think
that i've ever gotten
since the time that i i did this deal
with christian booksellers and got the
entire
uh antonicean and post nicean
christian fathers thing which was some
boxes as well this is 35 pounds so this
is quite a
haul pulling it you know
up from the mail room and bringing it in
and i'm really quite interested to see
what we've got in here um
looks like it's gonna be a little bit of
doing to get this this thing open
um
i mean this is
put together to really make it through
through anything i i suppose so there
you go snip snip
and let's see what we actually
have in here so
this is i can already tell looking at it
it's kind of an interesting haul
and some of the things are not
necessarily connected to
stoicism but they're interesting
nonetheless so i'm going to just
go through all the books that are in
here and and show them to you and
show you what we what we got right so
peter drucker's management revised
edition that's that's good for me to
have for my business ethics classes
and then we've got uh diogenes laertes
lives of the eminent philosophers now i
have this in the lobe edition but this
is kind of nice to have oh nice
drawings and paintings in here so that
is quite a
cool haul
and now looking at the rest
it's a lot of it looks like stuff that
that has to do with stoicism but maybe
not everything decision quality value
creation for better business decisions a
book i don't have well worth
checking out for me
let's see what else we have in here that
might not be
stoic
related
um
as a matter of fact it looks like almost
everything else
is going to be connected let me see what
the books over here to one or to the
other so we have another diogenes layer
thing specifically on the stoics i can
pass this off to
somebody and that'll be nice
for our local meetup group
um where to start so i'll start with
some that i already have farnsworth the
practicing stoic
this is kind of a nice well-regarded
book um
it's mostly just quotes from from
various stoics and and from other people
talking about stoicism but farnsworth
put it into a nice arrangement and
there's some introductions to it that
are kind of cool
we've got ellen busari's stoic spiritual
exercises which i do not have so
this will be nice for me
to to have
um we have donald robertson's how to
think like a roman emperor which i do
not have a copy of at this point in time
so i can finally get around to reading
it and reviewing it
um another big
great haul my colleague peter
stankuich's manual of reformed stoicism
now i have a review copy of this in
pdf but it's like watermarked and all of
that
and this is the actual book this is an
expensive book vernon press makes things
uh they're not affordable so i didn't
buy this because i you know i thought
i'd get it at the library so it's really
great
to have it
um
here's a penguin edition of seneca on
the shortness of life and it's got the
consolation to
uh
helvetia and on tranquility of mine i
can pass this off to somebody as well
um
what else have we got
um
so there's a couple seneca
additions in here
that i'll pull out
right now
we have the
anger mercy revenge volume that's got on
anger and on clemency and also
interestingly enough a play that seneca
wrote where he's making fun of
claudius we've got seneca's letters on
ethics these are all the university of
chicago editions and then we've got the
seneca hardship and happiness
one as well which has got a lot of great
stuff in it so i i've actually got um
copies of those already and i will find
somebody else
uh worthy
and fitting to pass those on too
what else have we got
this is neat jon sellers the pocket
stoick my friend and colleague john
um i i have not seen this before i'm
gonna have to check this out
i do have um no actually i don't have
this this uh
version i think or do i of sellers
stoicism i think i have a different
seller's book so this will be a nice
addition to the library
and then we've got uh some some cicero
stuff in here
as well
uh let's see what we got
um
here we go so
the on moral ends and cicero's on duties
both of which i i have i know somebody
else who can use these though so i'll be
passing them off to them and the cicero
on the emotions translation by margaret
graver of tusculin disputations three
and four also great study material that
i can pass off to
others i i think i actually have this
particular edition of epictetus
discourses and selected writings um yeah
so so this this will be great for our
milwaukee stoic fellowship this is one
that i can circulate around
make part of our little lending library
we've got two
different editions of marcus aurelius's
meditations
these will be nice supplements for me
because you know you look at the
different translations of them i read it
in the greek when i need to but um it's
always nice to see what other people are
making of them so we got the heart
translate the haze translation and the
robin waterfield translation
um we also have this
a life of marcus aurelius by
frank mclin
this i haven't read so this will be nice
nice for me um
and i will
you know look forward to that
um john sellers book on marcus aurelius
as well this is great a lot of sellers
in here which is which is cool oh this
one got
this one got a little bit bent up but
it's still good if you haven't read
becker's a new stoicism
it's worth reading it is very tough
reading becker is not an easy
writer
interestingly this client become friend
of mine we worked our way through this
entire book
over the course of months and it's so
dense
i've actually considered doing something
like the half hour hegel series but for
lawrence becker's uh new stoicism we'll
see about that down
down the line as a matter of fact i'm
going to get rid of the box
at this point in time and just take all
these books out since the box is uh
getting a little bit empty and unwieldy
so let's see what we got here
a couple adobe books um
the inner citadel which i don't have
really nice to have philosophy is a way
of life i've been using a pdf of that so
it's nice to have the actual
copy of it or i would take it out of the
local library and and that was nice
this i'd also don't have as well um
philosophy for life and other dangerous
situations ancient philosophy for modern
problems by jules evans who uh i've met
before very briefly at stoicon
28 2016 right
so this will be cool to read
the new ryan holiday book lives of the
stoics the art of living from xeno
demarcus aurelius i'm not a big holiday
fan but i've been you know wanting to
check this out and see what he actually
made of this so it'll be worth
going into
uh tom morris oh this is by the guy who
wrote if aristotle ran general motors a
good business ethics book from a long
time ago it'll be interesting to see
what he does with stoicism he's got a
book the stoic art of living inner
resilience and outer results
if aristotle wrote
ran general motors kind of a hit or miss
book this might be as well
a longs epictetus a stoic and socratic
guide to life i've used the library copy
of this having my own copy will be very
very nice by a long anthony
long one of the great
researchers of hellenistic philosophy
also the stoicon speaker
in 2018 cool guy too i got to meet him
and his wife and
you know it's like meeting a rock star
right um this one i don't know uh but
this looks quite interesting happiness
is overrated by raymond
angelo belliotti
and looking at the table of contents
little sassy wants to get in here
um it's about greek roman and christian
happiness happiness reconceived and
contemporary philosophical views the
paths of happiness other pretty
interesting book i'll definitely check
that out
another copy of letters from a stoic
different edition the penguin edition by
seneca this all definitely passed off to
somebody now this is one i haven't had
everything has two handles the stoics
guide to the art of living by somebody
who i've interacted with in the past
ronald peace
who has written for stoicism today
presented at stoicon and i've met him a
couple times so i'm looking forward to
checking that out
we're getting close to the bottom of the
pile we have uh william farrell's
meditations on self-discipline and
failure i've got a copy of this so i'll
pass this on as well i've already
reviewed that one
this one i don't have the stoics a guide
for the perplexed by
hollow check and we will see
what this is this is like
um i don't know this author uh looks
like it's heavily endnoted and uh
probably well researched so that'll be
good to check out
another one i don't don't actually know
the stoics by fa f h sandbach emeritus
professor of classics so this is this is
an older book published in 1975
and it looks like it's uh you know an
academic treatise
um so that'll be worth checking out
stoicism and emotion i just did an un uh
boxing video of this last week be and i
was so happy to have a copy of it
finally uh because that mine got
recalled by the marquette university
library there's a long story you can
find out on the other video
i recommend this book to so many people
i will definitely pass this on to
somebody who i i know can use it and i
already have a person in mind
finally um
michael bruce and stephen barbone just
the arguments 100 of the most most
important arguments in western
philosophy be interesting to see what
they consider to be the most important
arguments looks like it's divided into
you know epistemology
philosophy of religion ethics
philosophy of mind science and language
metaphysics so this will be interesting
as well so quite a
haul of books we'll stack these up
here and you can get some idea
of how much stuff has just
come in
so um
you know i would say that about
i would say that about um
at least a third to a half of these i'm
going to be
passing on to other people
some of them i'm going to be keeping
because i don't already have copies of
them and it's nice to have that but many
of these will find their way to
other people's hands particularly in the
milwaukee stoic fellowship
and so it will be quite nice to
send these on to some
other people who can definitely get some
uh some mileage
out of them winds blowing these books
around got the windows open so um
you know this is very generous of of my
my friend to
send these in this giant
bankers box now very light
previously was 35 pounds
if you love books as much as i do
then i think you'll get a kick out of
this haul if you're into stoicism like i
am you'll probably also
find this interesting as well and i
don't really have anything more to say
so i'm going to stop the video
here and there we go there's the books
you